that is an avenger you showed me that
you don't need super powers to be a hero
i broke my tailbone doing that
you want to be a superhero
there's a lot to lose
that's the things you gain like trick
arrows some cool costumes what's that on
his head that's a nature for hawkeye oh
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
marvel studios hawkeye streaming
november 24th only on disney plus some
people have actually called me the
world's greatest archer
are you one of those people
finding the banter between clint and
kate where are you no relax i'm taking
the elevator it came pretty naturally
i'm surprisingly capable yeah their
chemistry was so on
communicating listening
they can bicker and have you giggling
behind the monitors but then you see
them in action sequences and it's just
lightning
the intersection of those two characters
becomes really the big base of what this
show's about i begrudgingly have her as
a partner if you will and then our
friendship grows we certainly get her
butt kicked all over the show
i enjoy the humor and the tone in the
twists and turns that it takes
collaborating with jeremy it requires a
lot more strength than i think it it
looks like it might a lot
definitely not this one you don't have
to say definitely like that it's been
such a wild ride
you have no idea this is literally just
the bare bones of what this is going to
be
holy your problem is branding no my
problem is you
[Music]
you